- Hello everyone.
I'm Maurice Samuels, the director
of the Yale Program for
the Study of Antisemitism.
And it's my great pleasure to welcome you
to our first talk of the
2021-'22 academic year
in our Benjamin and Barbara
Zucker Lecture Series.
I could not have asked
for a better speaker
to start things off.
Jeffrey Herbst is the president
of the American Jewish University
in Los Angeles, California,
and has previously served
as the president of Colgate University,
as president of the
Newseum in Washington, DC,
and as provost of Miami University.
He's a professor of political science
specializing in comparative
politics and is the author
of "State Politics in Zimbabwe," 1990,
and "States and Power in Africa,
"Comparative Lessons in
Authority and Control," of 2000,
which received the Luebbert Best Book Award
in Comparative Politics
from the American Political
Science Association.
I should add that Jeffrey
Herbst is a Yale alum.
He received his PhD from
Yale in 1987, and when I read
the thoughtful and
thought provoking article
on campus antisemitism that
he published this summer
in Inside Higher Ed, and I
saw that he had gone to Yale,
I realized that he would
be the perfect person
to help us think through the question
of how to talk about Middle
East politics on campus
in this time of escalating conflict.
As some of you know, this
talk is all the more timely
after the recent discovery of racist
and antisemitic graffiti on
the Yale campus this past week.
So here's how, excuse
me, things will work.
President Herbst will speak
for about 30 or 40 minutes,
after which he will take
questions from the audience.
So please submit your questions
at any time during the talk,
using the Q&A button at
the bottom of your screen.
And then I will ask those
questions anonymously.
The chat function is disabled.
So please don't use that,
and we will end at 6:00 PM.
The title of today's talk is,
Antisemitism and Free
Speech on College Campuses.
Please join me in
welcoming Jeffrey Herbst.
- Professor Samuels,
thank you so very much.
It's a pleasure to speak
to a Yale audience.
I wish I could be in New
Haven, but I'm grateful
that we have the technology
that allows me to address you
on this important topic.
To situate myself in this
discussion, I am a Jew,
who's concerned, of
course, about antisemitism.
And as Professor Samuels
said, I am president
of a faith-based institution and have been
a college administrator for some time.
I'm also the former head of
the Newseum in Washington, DC,
a cultural institution that was based
on the first amendment.
So not only do I have an
appreciation of the value
of our free speech protections,
but I have consistently
argued that the solution
to bad speech is more speech.
I still believe that even
when there is an issue
such as antisemitism that I'm
personally concerned with.
Of course, the free speech protections
of the first amendment
technically do not apply
to private colleges, such as Yale,
because the free speech
guarantees in the constitution
are protections from
government censorship.
However, I think we would all agree
that Yale and other
private colleges aspire
to the same free speech climate
that is constitutionally
guaranteed in public schools.
And just to be clear, and to
make it even more complicated,
a significant amount
of what people consider
to be hate speech, including
some antisemitic remarks,
are, contrary to public belief,
constitutionally protected.
The ability to ban speech is constricted
and depends on the immediacy
and specificity of the threat.
That being said, of course,
there's a great deal
of difference about what you can say
and what you should say.
Finally, I approach this topic gingerly,
especially as much of it
will focus on antisemitism
and the relationship to ongoing debate
about the Middle East because
charges and discussions
about antisemitism can
sometimes take all the oxygen
out of the room and cause
us to avoid other issues.
For instance, in the
case of Nicholas Kristof,
the New York Times
correspondent who's argued,
albeit in a tentative manner that Israel
should not defend itself
from Hamas rocket attacks,
Kristof defends himself by
saying, and it's not antisemitic
to criticize Israel for
possible war crimes.
It's not, but it's also
could just be wrong.
And the fact that critics
can sometimes be wrong,
but not be antisemitic
is sometimes missed.
Finally, in this discussion,
I think the stakes
are actually even higher than
for people, including Jews,
but not limited, of
course, who are worried
about antisemitism or people
who want to debate the Middle East.
Residential colleges such as Yale,
along with military bases,
despite their many problems,
are among the most diverse
residential settings
in the United States, in
an increasingly polarized
and segmented society.
Residential colleges
have a bedrock commitment
to making all feel part of their community
and to free speech, even if one or both
of those core commitments
are violated in practice.
If there cannot be open,
passionate debate about Israel
and U.S. foreign policy in the Middle East
without lurching into antisemitism,
then I'm afraid there's not
much hope for good debate
in the rest of our society.
If, on the other hand, as I hope,
and as I'll argue throughout this talk,
colleges and universities can
model what civil discourse
actually means, then I think there is hope
for the rest of this society
also debating these issues
in a manner that's constructive.
Of course, Israel has
been a contentious issue
on college campuses for decades.
When I was a student at
Princeton in the early 1980s,
Israel had invaded Lebanon,
and there was enormous
amount of controversy
about those actions.
However, I was, at that
time, and for years after,
relatively sanguine about the
atmosphere for Jewish students
on most college campuses.
Indeed, a decade ago, I was
giving talks where I argued
contrary to growing fears at the time,
that antisemitism on college campuses
was not that much of a problem
outside of a relatively few
large public universities.
I wasn't wrong, I believe at the time,
but I think the situation has changed
and I'm concerned now, very concerned.
The indicators regarding
college antisemitism
have been flashing red for some time.
Hillel reported that antisemitic incidents
on college campuses rose to
an all time high in 2019-20,
even with the closure of
many due to the pandemic.
There's been a constant drum
beat of antisemitic incidents
that have grown disheartening.
At the University of Southern California,
a Jewish student was forced
to resign as vice president
of the student government after harassment
because of her pro-Israel views.
At Arizona State University,
Hitler Was Right posters
have been taken down several times.
At the University of
Connecticut, there have been
repeated incidents of
antisemitic graffiti,
and verbal insults of the
type that Professor Samuels
reported on the Yale
campus just this week.
A new poll surveying members of a leading
predominantly Jewish
fraternity and sorority found
that more than 65% of the respondents
have felt unsafe on campus
due to antisemitic attacks
with one in 10 reporting
that they have fear
of physical assault because
they are openly Jewish.
Additionally, nearly
70% of the students said
that personally experienced
or were familiar with an act
of antisemitism on campus or
in a virtual campus setting
in the last 120 days.
As a result, and this is
particularly disheartening,
about 50% said they had
hidden their Jewish identities
and more than half have avoided expressing
their views on Israel.
That's terrible, both
for the students involved
and for all of us who
hope that a college campus
will be welcoming, safe and
openly vibrant for all students.
More generally, across Jewish communities
in North America, there
is a real fear today
about the collegiate
environment that Jewish students
and supporters of Israel face.
This has been fed by a
constant drip of stories
about physical confrontations
that Jewish students
have had as well as a feeling
that college administrators
have not treated antisemitism
with the same seriousness
that they address other forms of hatred.
It pains me to say this, but today,
I was talking to a friend
and I was telling her
that I was giving a
talk to a Yale audience,
and she told me that recently
her daughter had been advised
by a college counselor
not to apply to Yale
because it had a difficult
environment for Jewish students.
Now, I know it's very
difficult to place one story
in any particular context,
and I know there's a lot
of disinformation out
there and I see no data
that Yale is actually more
hostile to Jewish students
than any other campus or
certainly its competitors.
However, that is the kind of
story and that is the kind
of discussion that is
out there and that is now
being entertained by large
parts of the Jewish community
that would, I think, have been
inconceivable a decade ago.
So I think the concern
should be very real.
Now, why is all this happening?
Part of it that a situation
in the United States
is becoming more polarized,
public expressions of hatred
towards many different
groups are increasing,
and this inevitably falls
partially to the Jews.
According to recent FBI statistics,
American Jews, who make up no more than 2%
of the U.S. population
are targets of nearly 60%
of religious bias.
Antisemitism on college
campuses has, in particular,
morphed over time from
old stereotypes about Jews
to collateral damage from
heated discussions about Israel,
Palestine, the Middle East
and the United States' role
in that region.
This is somewhat different than debates
in the public outside of colleges,
where old stereotypes of
Jews still often dominate
antisemitic attacks, and
certainly, we saw in the upsurge
in violence against Jews
across U.S. cities in May,
as a result of the Gaza conflict,
that there is a continuing
rise of antisemitism,
and this plays back on college
campuses where the dynamic
about heated debates about the Middle East
are turning into, sometimes,
antisemitic attacks
has been of primary
concern to Jewish students.
What else is different, I think,
is that the institutional
settings of debate
about Israel, Palestine, the Middle East,
the United States' role
is being challenged.
And I think this is of particular concern
to people as myself, who
both value a safe environment
for all students and one
which promotes free speech.
Opponents of Israel
have taken as a strategy
from migrating from individual voice,
which I view as protected
and often welcome,
to demanding that institutions
on college campuses
take positions, something
that I view as frightening
and quite often inappropriate.
Here I'll focus in part
on the Yale campus,
both because I'm nominally
speaking to a Yale audience,
and because as Professor Samuels noted,
I'm an alum of this institution.
But also, because what's
playing out on the Yale campus
is playing out on many
other college campuses
across this country.
Now, of course, many scholars, no doubt,
including some at Yale,
have signed letters
in their personal capacity
strongly opposing Israel
during the Gaza violence.
I can argue with these individuals who,
I believe, are sometimes
right, sometimes wrong,
sometimes misinformed,
sometimes antisemitic.
However, they're using
their voice to express
their individual opinion and
I or others in the community
are free to disagree with them
on an equal playing field.
While I might regret
personally their views,
I defend their right in
most cases to have them,
and I look forward to debating them.
However, what has changed is that now,
some institutions on college campuses
are being asked to take positions.
As was noted widely on
your campus in June,
the Yale College Council
adopted a statement
of condemnation of Israel
that noted, in part,
"As Yale students, we
condemn the injustice,
"ethnic cleansing and genocide
occurring in Palestine,"
and continued, "Just as
Israel's military imposes
"the apartheid system
against Palestinians,
"the U.S. police enforces
a system of white supremacy
"against Black Americans."
Now I view those statements
as exceptionally problematic,
because I do not believe,
and I can argue this
at greater length, that
ethnic cleansing or genocide,
in fact, characterizes
what is going on in Israel
and the Palestinian Territories.
And as someone who observed
firsthand, who studied,
wrote about apartheid in South Africa,
I do not believe that it is an application
where Arab-Israelis have full
political rights in Israel,
and where there is now
an Arab political party
in the ruling coalition.
I don't know the exact
origins of their resolution,
and I would surmise that
there was a fair amount
of virtue signaling and other politicking.
I do know that it was unfortunate,
because I think that a student
government could have done
a good turn in setting
parameters for an open, free,
fierce debate about Israel, but instead,
went in another direction, and
in fact, closing off debate
and adopting a position
which it knew many students
would disagree with or
feel comfortable with.
Still, these are young people,
and as Deborah Lipstadt,
the Biden administration's
nominee for a special envoy
to fight antisemitism has noted,
when looking at antisemites,
we should differentiate
between the simple one and the wicked one.
As regrettable as the student
government's views were,
I'm under no illusion
that students governments
are particularly important
and have much of a power
to structure conversation on campus.
It is certainly possible, of
course, that the statement
could feel threatening
to individual students,
Jewish or non-Jewish, who
are supportive of Israel,
and that would be unfortunate.
More likely, it will lead
to the de-legitimization
of the student government itself.
Of course, there's not much
the Yale administration
could have done about what the
student government proclaims.
It could have issued a statement contrary,
but I understand why
administrators might be reluctant
to react to every student
government statement.
Much more problematic in my view
were some faculty
statements that have emerged
from particular programs.
The faculty in Ethnicity,
Race and Migration,
issued a statement on Palestine
on May 17th that said,
"As scholars in the program,
"we recognize the Palestinian struggle
"as an indigenous liberation movement
"confronting a settler colonial state
"illegally expropriating
their land for over 70 years."
Members of the Yale
program went on to say,
"We express solidarity
with the Palestinian people
"as they resist the many forms
of Israeli state violence
"and fight for their freedom.
"We will amplify the voices
of Palestinian scholars
"and center the anti-colonial struggles
"in our academic and political practice."
No talk here, of course,
to return to the 1967 lines
or anything else.
This is about the
de-legitimization of Israel
and the promotion of a
particular perspective,
and as they say, their
academic and public practice.
Similarly, the Yale's Women,
Gender and Sexuality Studies
program signed a letter,
also endorsed by dozens
of other women's and
gender studies programs
across the country, titled,
Gender Studies Departments in Solidary
with Palestinian Feminist Collective,
that, among other things,
endorsed the unambiguous right
of return for Palestinians,
which depending
on what this actually means would amount
to the destruction of
Israel as a Jewish state.
Further, the letter said,
"We do not subscribe to a," quote,
"both sides," unquote,
"rhetoric that erases
"the military, economic,
media and global power
"that Israel has over Palestine.
"This is not a conflict," in quote,
"that is too controversial and complex,"
in quotes, "to assess."
I'll get to the substantive
issues with regard to Israel
in a moment, but I think
stepping back from Israel
and antisemitism that these statements
are exceptionally problematic
for a number of reasons.
Speech and debate, the very
things that these programs
and others at a university
were designed to encourage
are being stifled.
Here, I'm concerned about
the boundaries of free speech
being curtailed because
those who have the power
and make no mistake, the
professors and faculty
in these programs speak
from a privileged position
in the hierarchy at Yale,
are predetermining in the outcome
of certain intellectual debates.
Indeed, they are de-legitimizing anyone
who has an opposing view.
No less than the American Association
of University Professors, in
its 1940 profound statement
on principles on academic
freedom and tenure,
defined the prevailing
professional standards
of academic freedom of faculty.
It stated, "As scholars
and educational officers,
"they, teachers, should
remember that the public
"may judge their profession
and their institution
"by their utterances.
"Hence they should, at
all times be accurate,
"should exercise appropriate restraint,
"should show respect for
the opinion of others
"and should make every effort to indicate
"that they are not speaking
for the institution."
Academic freedom is a
wonderful thing, but it comes
with certain profound responsibilities.
The implications of programs
taking on political positions
is that certain types
of research and outcomes
are privileged as well as implications
for hiring and teaching.
At its basis, I think this is
profoundly anti-intellectual,
by not only arguing the
other side is wrong,
but stating, really,
there is no other side.
Now I would say the exact same thing
if an East Asian Studies
department issued proclamations
about genocide against the Uyghurs.
Even though I personally
believe that genocide
is being conducted by
Beijing, but I don't believe
it's the role of an academic department
to take on political positions
that change the contours
of the free speech debate on campus.
I headed the Department
of Politics at Princeton
for five years, which I
believe is a distinguished
academic unit, and I
also have a lot of firm
and deeply held political beliefs.
It would never occur to me, frankly,
to get to the department to
endorse the positions I had
both because I didn't believe that others
necessarily believed them,
and I would've been worried
on the implications for our
students, graduate student,
departmental research and
the intellectual climate
that the department
was supposed to foster.
Jewish students and
those who are pro-Israel,
could legitimately complain, I think,
that these proclamations and others
cause a threatening environment.
I have no idea about the
individual sentiments
of the faculty who have
signed these proclamations,
but I know that these kinds of statements,
by de-legitimizing certain
intellectual positions,
provide an environment for
attack on supporters of Israel
and inevitably, because
their positions are seen
as illegitimate, attacks
which can verge on,
or leap over to antisemitism.
And of course, values that
support the resistance
without differentiation
of the Palestinians
is not even a veiled endorsement of Hamas.
It is an endorsement of
Hamas and its decision
to rain rockets down on Israelis,
both Jews and Palestinians.
It would have been easier to differentiate
some sort of support, vis-a-vis
some sorts of resistance,
but that was not done,
leading these programs
to implicitly endorse the
proudly antisemitic organization,
Hamas, that has at its
fundamental charter,
calling for the destruction
of the Jewish state.
Now it's my understanding,
although I'm not well aware
of the campus environment,
that many at Yale have not spoken out
against these programs' statements,
despite the fact that I believe
that they are significant departures
from academic standards.
I view that as unfortunate.
As someone who believes
that ethnicity, race,
migration and gender are
critically important to understand,
and who has tried to contribute
in some of those areas
and as a college administrator,
I would say, then,
when you do not engage with
colleagues who you believe
have violated the norms of the university,
you are essentially marginalizing them,
essentially not taking them
seriously enough to disagree.
As another Yalie has said,
"Those who do not confront these programs
"are guilty of the soft
bigotry of low expectations."
Why have universities
had such trouble dealing
with antisemitism and
why is there such concern
among Jewish students
and significant worry
that the problem will get
worse in the coming years,
despite the fact that many universities
with the best of
intentions, including Yale,
have devoted enormous resources
to student affairs offices,
to diversity, to bias
training and the like?
Part of the answer is
that fighting hatred,
fighting bigotry on campuses is hard,
and I recognize that full stop.
But there are also other issues
that are specific to antisemitism.
Jewish students are often coded as white
by student affairs officers and by others.
Seen as a privileged portion of society,
the fact that these
students may be vulnerable
to antisemitic attacks is
not put on the same plane
of concern as possibilities of bigotry
and hatred devoted against
communities of color
who have, of course,
endured a tremendous amount
of bigotry and hatred.
This is despite the fact
that the recently released
Pew study on American Jewry found that 15%
of Jews under the age of
30, might reasonably include
the college population,
identify as Hispanic, Black,
Asian, or multi-racial.
Of course, no students
should be subject to hatred
or bigotry, but the fact
that Jews are not coded
as among those groups who
are traditionally been
the recipient of tremendous
hatred and bigotry,
produces, I would argue, some dissonance
in collegiate approaches to
how to deal with the problem.
It's also the case that some
portion, but by no means all,
of the antisemitic
attacks on Jewish students
who are supporters of
Israel come from people
who are involved in communities of color
and who college administrators code
as always being the recipients
of hatred and bigotry,
and not necessarily as the perpetrators.
What to do.
The common answer is always more speech.
That's been my answer for a long time,
but isn't what I'm saying is
that there's too much focus
on Israel right now, and the sheer focus
is part of what's propelling antisemitism?
I don't believe that, and
I'm fine with a lot of focus
on Israel, but I think it has to be done
with nuance and with care.
Although it's obvious, it is worth saying
that not every criticism
of Israel is antisemitic.
There are plenty of legitimate criticisms
and although heroic, powerful
voices like Natan Sharansky,
have argued that it's
antisemitic if Israel is treated
in a fundamentally different manner,
I'm not even sure of that.
On some level, it's true, of course,
but I don't take it that Israel,
but I take it that Israel should be held
to a higher standard than
Syria or other countries
in the Middle East because of
its own self-professed norms.
It wants to be held to a higher standards.
And yes, because it is a
major U.S. aid recipient.
However, that makes it
special, but not unique,
a differentiation that is important.
And I'm not sure why there
isn't additional speech
on other issues.
Take for instance, Ethiopia,
a country that I've studied,
that's part of my own academic work.
Ethiopia is a country that
the U.S. has given $13 billion
in aid over the last 20
years and that received,
until the recent civil war began,
around $3.5 billion in foreign assistance
from major donors each
year, including another
significant share from
multilateral institutions
which Americans, in part, share.
Because of the civil war
instigated in good part
by the federal government in Addis,
over 400,000 people,
according to a recent report
by the Council on Foreign Relations,
in Tigray Province are
living in famine conditions.
79% of pregnant and lactating women
screened over the course of a week
were found to suffer
from acute malnutrition
and only 11% of the
humanitarian supplies needed
in the region have actually
been delivered since July.
Delivery of medical supplies
to Tigray is prohibited
by the Ethiopian government,
as is the delivery of fuel,
making distribution of aid
that does make it to the region
extraordinarily difficult.
Now I'm not saying of course,
that you cannot talk about Israel
if you don't talk about Ethiopia.
What I am saying is
there should be more talk
about Ethiopia and in particular,
understanding that the world
is a complicated place.
If you come to an understanding
and a critique of Israel
after at least some review
of what is happening
in the rest of the world, then you have
a potentially respectable position
or at least one that can be argued with.
However, if you immediately
look at Israel is uniquely bad
without understanding how the world works,
then that is something else.
The Yale College Council has not taken
a thundering declaration on Tigray,
and women's studies programs
do not talk about women in Tigray.
Even closer to home,
I often wonder about the focus on Israel.
Here, I'll talk briefly about the Biden
and Obama administrations.
I'll skip Trump for the moment
only because the two others
are the ones likely that are supported
by a good part of the audience.
President Biden's administration
killed Zamari Ahmadi,
it's important to say his name,
by a drone in Afghanistan,
after he was going around
Kabul collecting water bottles.
Seven children were killed
in collateral damage
because of that drone attack.
Yet there has not been a
demand for a war crimes trial
for a military that
killed a person of color.
I can only imagine if
Netanyahu had done this.
More generally, according to the Bureau
of Investigative Journalism,
a total of 563 strikes,
largely by drones, targeted
Pakistan, Somalia and Yemen
during Obama's two terms,
about 10 times as many as under Bush.
Between 384 and 800 civilians were killed
in those countries, according
to a report log by the bureau.
And of course those countries,
unlike Gaza and Israel,
did not provide any direct
threat to the United States,
and I've been struck by
the fact that there's often
more debate about the
Israeli conduct of conflict
in the United States than there has been
about the American conduct of conflict.
Although you would think that Americans
are most concerned about the governments
that they themselves elect directly.
Now, why is this?
Well, lots of people are passionate
about Israel and Palestine.
I get that.
It's easier to cover
Gaza than it is Yemen.
That's an issue.
Some Americans are more
interested in criticizing
Netanyahu, who was still prime minister
during then the last Gaza conflict
than in the own leaders that they support.
That's less okay, I think.
Hamas has made a a tactical decision
to make its people vulnerable
and then use their deaths
as de-legitimating the
Israeli right to defense.
It has its supporters
and its fellow travelers
who have fallen in with
its media strategy.
And then, the Israel
conflict with Palestinians
has been used to link to U.S. conflict.
From Minneapolis to Palestine,
as the documents the Yale
students published say.
I don't wanna spend too
much time on this issue,
but I'll say, as someone
who's done field work
in countries with conflict,
that participants on the ground
understand their conflict
according to their own circumstances
without reference to
Minnesota or anywhere else.
You demean local participants,
both Israelis and Palestinians,
when you try to understand
them by placing them
in your conflict.
So, and then there are, of
course, outright antisemites
who jump all over any
controversy about Israel
to feed in their own bigotry.
What is clear is there's a
whole range of mixed motives
when there's more speech about Israel.
Some of it, a large part of
it, I would argue, is good.
Some of it is problematic.
What I do believe, what
I am in favor of is
when people such as
myself say more speech,
we really should say more careful speech.
I'm not interested in censoring anyone,
but I am interested in
encouraging everyone
to spend the time to
understand the nuances
and complexities of yes,
all sides of a conflict
and to try to put them into context
of the way the world operates.
The gain, the political
discussion has to be
on an even keel.
That's why I'm somewhat concerned
about student governments who can poison
collegiate atmospheres,
but I'm very concerned
about academic programs in
institutions that should serve
as a venue for arguments, not as a vector
for particular opinions
and who develop, in fact,
consciously anti-intellectual stances.
These programs and departments
go against the very idea
of the more careful speech
which I'm trying to promote.
To conclude, I'll say that
antisemitism is a problem
that suggests that, all data
suggests is going to get worse
on society at large and
on college campuses.
It is going to be an ongoing
concern and not go away.
And we are on the verge, as I
wrote in my article in August,
of some potentially very serious incidents
where physical harm is done to students,
and there's already a great deal
of mental and emotional anguish.
Colleges and universities
should go out of their way
to be proven grounds to
show how difficult issues
which people feel passionately
about can be discussed
without bigotry and animus.
Instead, they're going
in the opposite direction
and maybe the places where Israel
and the Middle East are least likely
to be productively discussed.
I think that would be unfortunate.
I think college administrators
should go out of their way
to socialize their
colleagues that antisemitism
is a real issue, that bigotry can affect
even those populations who
may be coded as privileged
and that administrators
are going to have to do
a tremendous amount of work and exert
significant political capital to make sure
that the speech environment
on their campuses
remains free and fair.
If we can do that, if we can
figure out a way to discuss
these issues without bigotry,
then I believe that colleges
and universities can
reassert their stature
as the primary intellectual
centers of American life
and model to a society,
which is polarized, divided,
and which is rife with bigotry and hatred,
how discussions can happen.
I'm not sure that will
occur on all campuses,
but across the 4,000
colleges and universities
in the United States, I
hope that these issues
so vitally important to
Israelis, Palestinians,
Jews, non-Jews, and a
great many other people
across the world can be developed in a way
that people feel is productive, important
and free of fear and hostility.
Professor Samuels, let me stop there.
As I said, I'm honored to
be able to talk with you,
delighted to be able to
address these subjects,
happy to answer any questions
that the audience may have.
- Okay. Terrific.
Thank you, Jeffrey.
We're really very grateful
for that really lucid
and nuanced presentation,
and I'm sure there gonna be
a lot of questions.
There already are some.
I ask, just to remind everybody,
to please submit your questions
using the Q&A function,
and I will ask them anonymously.
So while those are coming in,
I did have a few questions
of my own to get us going.
First of all, I was wondering
if you could just go back
the way you started the
presentation with the question
of freedom of speech, because
I think that that is something
that people find confusing and especially,
the distinction between public
and private universities,
is there any difference
in what kind of speech
is protected and not?
- The first amendment begins with
"Congress shall make no law."
So it applies to government censorship,
and it's been understood that it applies
to public universities that
are part of the American state.
So formally, the first amendment applies
to public universities, but
I'm sure my colleagues at Yale
and every place else,
certainly I felt this way
at Colgate and Princeton,
believe that everyone
on those campuses should have the same
rights of expression that
are formally guaranteed
when I was at Miami University
in Ohio, a public university.
So I think the constitution
may be one thing,
but I think the norms
that have been adopted
certainly suggest that
private universities
have aspired to the same
free speech environments
that public universities
are required to have.
- Okay. Thank you for that.
So here's a question that
I had, but I hear it echoed
in some of the questions
from the audience.
Can you be a little more specific
about why those statements
by the Yale College Council
or by the Ethnicity, Race and Migration,
I, we understand why you
think it's problematic,
but can you be a little
more specific about whether
and why you think that
they're antisemitic?
So, in other words, where is that,
this is another way of
asking the question,
where is the line between
anti-Zionism and antisemitism?
- I hope I was nuanced,
enough in my presentation.
I said that they can enable an environment
where attacks on supporters
of Israel can verge on
or lurch over to antisemitism.
That's the important issue,
to me, because first of all,
those statements change
the level playing field
that individuals have in
debating these issues.
And second, they go out of their way,
they were quite striking, I thought,
in de-legitimizing the other side.
It's not they said, we think
that the other side is wrong
on the facts or on the
data, or on our opinion.
They said it's illegitimate
to have a different opinion.
And the first statement
also said some things
about privileging certain perspectives
in the academic practice.
That has, I'm not saying that
that per se is antisemitic.
What I am saying is that enables
an antisemitic environment,
and I think is, before we
even get to antisemitism,
just exceptionally problematic
in terms of academic practice.
- Mm-hmm. Okay.
So another question that,
you know, as someone,
I think we both went
to college in the '80s,
when, and you referred to
the anti-apartheid movement
in the '80s, and I think a lot of people,
especially from our
generation, but others,
have a hard time understanding
what the difference is
between, you know, opposing
apartheid in the '80s
and opposing either just Israel to cour,
or the occupation, let's say now.
- Look, I mean, if you wanna
take a position on Israel
and oppose the occupation
as an individual,
that's your basis.
What I'm saying is that I was not aware,
when I was at Princeton or Yale,
when I was a graduate student
and Yale was a center of
Southern African studies
in the 1980s at the heart of it,
at the height of the apartheid conflict,
that individual programs were taking
political positions on this.
Yale's response to the divestment debate
in the 1980s was a wise one.
It said, we're not gonna divest,
but we're going to invest
significant resources
in the study of Southern Africa,
and develop what I believe
was the premiere center
for Southern African Studies at the time.
I thought that was exactly right.
When you have programs and
institutions take an opinion,
I think that changes
the nature of discourse.
And I think it can be read as part
of the politicization of
everything that we see.
Fewer personal relationships,
friendships across party lines,
fewer people trusting any
source from the other side,
and this politicization
of everything also fueled
by social media in its own way,
has leeched onto college
campuses, and it's a problem.
And I think it's one,
irrespective, I think,
as I said, of your opinion
on Israel, that I would hope
people would find problematic.
Just like I said, if a department
started taking positions
on other issues, even issues I agree with,
I would find it problematic.
- So I think to play devil's advocate,
and I have definitely heard this argument
from people involved, especially, I think,
in Women, Gender and Sexuality Studies,
Ethnicity, Race and
Migration, they would say,
or I have heard some people
say that their scholarship
is about that kind of
direct political action.
So they don't really acknowledge, I think,
a distinction between their scholarship
and their advocacy, let's say.
So how do you-
- I would say their
scholarship is their business
and their individual
advocacy is their business,
and they have the right to
pursue those intellectual
and advocacy paths, absolutely.
It's where you invoke
institutional authority
that I think the line is crossed.
- Mm-hmm.
Okay, and what, there's
an interesting question
from the audience about,
there's been so much in the news
just this week about the
influence of social media
on these questions.
So can you say something about
how social media platforms
have kind of driven the
kind of polarization
that we're seeing on college campuses?
- Yeah.
This is a generalization,
but I'll start here.
In the 1980s, when the College Democrats
and the College Republicans
on a particular campus,
had to find someone to
talk with and debate,
they found each other and
they debated each other
and maybe they agreed,
or maybe they disagreed,
but they were talking with each other
and being human beings,
they recognized each other's humanity
and friendships and social ties developed.
Now people can live if
they're College Democrats
or College Republicans or anything else,
in their own ecosystem on social media,
without finding anyone who
ever disagrees with them
and any reason to moderate your views.
So the filter bubble of social media,
to borrow from a well-known praise,
I think has caused the
increasing polarization
of American society on
just about every issue,
because the need to mediate positions
in order to be culturally acceptable,
in order to develop
ties is no longer there.
And in fact, almost anyone,
with no matter how extreme views
can find others who share
those views, when in the past,
there might've been others out there,
but they weren't in the same town.
So social media, which I
have a, at the Newseum,
I celebrated social media
as the greatest explosion
of public expression in human history.
I still believe that
and many wonderful things have occurred.
As another saying goes,
the people formerly known
as the audience now are able to speak,
but some of what the
audience says, we found out,
some of what we've been thinking
privately, in some cases,
turns out to be problematic.
And along with a great
increase in democratization
has come increased expressions
of bigotry, hatred,
across many different levels,
expressions of violence,
as well as the ability of
human traffickers, terrorists
and others to organize.
So we have engaged in, let's
say over the last 15 years,
we've completely changed
our method of discourse
and it's not exactly surprising
that norms haven't kept up.
Whether those norms will
ever reach where we are
in social media, I don't know.
I'd like to think.
circling back to the topic,
that colleges and universities can be,
so it both works against
the corrosive effects
of social media, but it's
hard because our students
are the very ones who are most wired in
and who have now, you
know, in their short lives,
had lives which have
been completely dominated
by social media.
- Okay. Thank you.
So we're getting really
a lot of questions here.
So here's an interesting one
and one that I've faced before too,
certainly running a program devoted
to the study of antisemitism.
Do you think at all that
the calling out antisemitism
can result in shutting down
dialogue on college campus
and how to negotiate that.
You know, how-
- Sure.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
Look, no one, no side
is right all the time.
And there are certainly been accusations
of antisemitism which are incorrect,
and I'll say there have
certainly been people
who have tried to use the
weapon of antisemitism
to shut down debate.
That's happened, and it's a
possibility, and as I noted
at the beginning of my talk, you know,
sometimes I'm ambivalent about
talking about antisemitism
because it immediately sucks
all the oxygen out of the room.
Because you can't argue,
well, I just disagree with you
without going to an antisemitic problem.
How to negotiate that is very difficult.
Sharansky has a three-part test.
I think that's interesting in terms
of how Israel is treated.
I opted for something more
ambiguous in my talk, frankly,
and I give a lot of thought to this
in preparation for this talk.
I think it depends on
whether those talking
have exhibited some kind
of reasoned approach
to where they got to their position.
That's hard, that's easy
to say and hard to discern,
but I'm gonna stick with it for the moment
because I'm not willing to
immediately shut down debate.
I think that's bad.
So I wanna say, I wanna
challenge people to say,
how did you get here?
What was the process that you got there?
And if we can discuss that process,
which is a long and difficult discourse,
then maybe I still disagree with you,
but I respect your sentiments.
And I think that's the kind of discourse
that colleges and universities
should be especially good at.
- Okay, so what do you think,
this is maybe a touchy question,
but you can answer it how you'd like.
What do you think President
Salovey should have done
in response to, let's not
say the YCC statement,
but the ERM and Women's
Studies statements.
What would your advice
to him have been to do?
- Right.
You know, I'm hopefully modest
in my recommendations of a campus
I haven't been on in a long
time and in a situation
that I don't know well.
I believe that these issues
and, you know, the statement from,
the first statement is
on the Yale website.
The second statement I pulled off the web.
I believe that these
issues and these statements
and the issues they raised
rose to the importance
that a college administrator should say,
look, this is problematic
from the institution's stance.
This is just over the line.
It is not about academic freedom,
which is assigned to individuals,
not programs or centers.
It is about the institution's
ability to conduct
its core enterprise,
intellectual discourse,
and I would've recommended
to any president
who had centers or programs on this,
that they make clear their
opposition and explain,
because I think this is
an important moment why.
This is not in this case,
an issue about Israel.
I don't think it is.
I don't think the Department of Economics
should be issuing
statements about how much
deficit spending is appropriate,
even though I'm sure
economists have all
kinds of views about it.
It's just not what college
programs should be doing.
So I would've advised them to oppose it.
- And it's interesting. I think,
that in general, Political
Science Departments
are really the least likely to issue
these kinds of statements,
at least it seems like,
or to pass BDS resolutions, it seems.
You know, I don't know if
you could say something
about why you think that these
more identity-focused programs have been
the ones to do this.
- You know, I haven't been in the debates
that had these programs had.
I wasn't part of the processes
that were taken where
these votes, where votes were
taken, if votes were taken.
I think it goes back to
what you asked before,
which is advocacy and
scholarship, in some areas,
is more directly manifests itself.
Not only in these areas.
I have friends who are
constitutional scholars
who are in Political Science departments
who have their own advocacy, for sure,
of their own political positions.
But the scholars in both programs, take,
as part of their intellectual
enterprise argument,
political arguments that their programs
should adopt these platforms.
And so, that's the best that I can say
without being part of
the debates themselves.
- Yeah, I mean, you know,
my experience is that,
and I was involved in some of the efforts
to keep the Modern Language Association
from adopting a pro-BDS platform,
and I really thought that
was gonna pass easily
because there seemed to be a
lot of very strong supporters
and what really emerged was
that there were a lot of
very, there was a small group,
a relatively small group of
very committed pro-BDS people,
but that they were the
ones making the most noise.
And that in fact, the
larger membership of the MLA
was not so anti-Israel, and
I think there's some of that,
that those voices tend to be
the ones kind of controlling
what's going on.
I don't know if you've found that.
- Well, you know, I think
that's often the case.
I would say that people
who may (audio cuts out),
another manifestation of
the problematic nature
of these proclamations is
that you will now be asked
your political opinion
on every single issue.
What about this? What about that?
And some programs, I think,
have found themselves bogged
down in endless debates
about their political positions,
and they should've never
gone down that route in the first place.
As I said, if individuals
wanna scholarship and advocacy,
that's their business.
It's when you invoke
institutional authority
that it becomes, I think,
problematic for the university
and challenging for supporters
and others on campuses.
- Okay, and what do you, I
don't know if you can say
anything about the effort
to promote the working,
the so-called working
definition of antisemitism
as a kind of campus speech code.
Do you have any feelings about that?
- I'm opposed to speech codes.
Before we get, even into the particulars
of which definition of antisemitism,
I think colleges and universities,
when they start regulating
speech, are in for trouble.
And I think it's
particularly inappropriate
on a college or university campus.
- What, here's a question
that I've seen echoed
and several of the people have asked,
and I'll ask it in two parts.
So, first of all, what
would you say to parents
of students who, many Jewish
students who supported
that YCC statement?
I think there are a lot of parents
who are confused about, you know,
how Jewish students now could sign on
to what seems like an
anti-Israel statement.
So, first of all, how
do you, I'm sure you,
as the president of
American Jewish University,
you might have some experience.
And then also, what you would
advise, what you would tell
a Jewish student on campus
now who feels uncomfortable
in the current situation,
what advice you would give.
- Those are two profound questions
and my children, all in their 20s,
graduated from college not that long ago.
Look, on the first
question, there are a lot
of intergenerational debates
about Israel right now
in our society, including among families.
I would say, talk to your
students, take them seriously.
Don't believe that
they've been brainwashed
and understand where they're coming from.
If you disagree with
them, argue with them.
Not in terms of parental authority,
but take them seriously and
take their arguments seriously.
And you may find that you reach
a meeting of the minds, or you may not.
You can't always reach
agreement, but I think
all relationships are improved when people
take each other seriously.
In terms of Jewish students,
and I'll refer back
to the story of the beginning,
I tell the guidance counselor
who advised the person,
the student, not to apply to
Yale that they were wrong.
I would say that's the ultimate
victory for the antisemites,
that first of all, I don't believe
that Jewish students shouldn't go to Yale.
I believe they should, but I
believe that Jewish students
like everyone else, should
go wherever they want,
and should apply to wherever they want,
and for the students who are afraid,
sometimes legitimately, I'd
say that this is the moment
to organize and to be more forthright
about your political
positions and identity,
to seek allies on the campus community
and with college administrators,
but that, in the end,
I believe that antisemitism
will be furthered
if we try to hide from
it rather confront it.
Now, I recognize easy for me to say,
I occupy a particular position on a campus
and students are naturally,
often, conflict averse,
afraid to lose friends and the like,
but this is the world in which we live.
And I think if you can develop the tools,
the attitude, the mindset to
not only have a set of beliefs,
but to feel comfortable with them
and not to feel threatened,
that's an important set of life skills.
- Okay. Terrific.
Well, this gets us right to
the end of our time today.
I wanna encourage people
to read your great article
from over the summer, and I think,
if I don't have the link in front of me,
but if you Google Jeffrey
Herbst and Inside Higher Ed,
it'll come right up.
So please, you know, you're
not gonna be able to see
all the clapping hands, but
I will do it for everybody.
And on behalf of our very
large audience today,
I wanna just say thank you for
taking the time to do this,
and for your thoughtful presentation.
And I encourage everyone who is here today
to please sign up for the
YPSA, the YPSA mailing list.
We have a whole range of
very interesting talks
planned for this year,
and I hope to see you
back at a future event.
So thank you again, Jeffrey.
- Thank you so very much.
-  Bye-bye, everybody.